I want you to think about your name is
Cornelius Vanderbilt the legendary
Vanderbilt family your mother gives you
a hundred dollars at 16 years old you
turn that hundred dollars in today's
money to 200 billion dollars two
generations later one of your grandsons
decides to build a hundred and seventy
five thousand square foot vacation home
32 bedrooms 45 bathrooms 225 rooms of
today's money it would have cost you 1.6
billion dollars and then you lose all
that 200 billion dollars of wealth in
two generations that's why today you
don't know any Vanderbilts because
generational wealth wasn't passed on
because the right thing wasn't put in
place because of that I got four kids
this is a topic that's keeping me up at
night if you want to find out how to
create generational wealth there's a
handful of ways doing it or if you want
to find out how to protect it I'm
posting a free webinar if you want to
join me on this to see start getting
passed already very quickly click on a
link above click on a link below sign up
get registered I'll see you there it's
limited seating